press against okay Caleb I've been asked
us try and respond to you and I think
you're right on the money to do the
hammer on the nail or whatever the right
way as we see things that little ol wpb
we would expect 2009 actually quite a
difficult year i don't think i would say
that things necessarily will recover in
2009 but to the first half is going to
be pretty awful second half i think
we'll be able I look at our budgets the
way we look at things and this time of
the year pretty much flat revenues for
the year but certainly the first half is
tougher and the second half gets a
little bit better all these things are
relative so first laughter second half
at 2009 I think I'd expect 2010 to be in
the real world at least to be a little
better here at Dallas if you take what
give people say here as being important
or serious certainly serious or whether
it's important or not hear what they're
saying is they're being pretty gloomy
pretty pessimistic I think that's pretty
uniformly of the case and I would be
identified as an optimist rubini The
Economist will probably be the most make
talking about 11 part of 2010's recovery
point in the real world or maybe even
later the other thing I think you'll see
is that the back half of 2009 the second
half 2009 we'll see recovering the
financial markets and that recovery will
be sharper than people anticipate
because there's a lot of money on the
sidelines what do we have to do to get
no well I think that fiscal stimulus
with Keynesian stimulus and the people
insist on calling it now it is so great
I think and our social assembly see this
morning they were talking about as much
as a trillion dollars been injected into
the US economy in the Roman bothering
another the u.s. 14 trillion dollars is
around 40 trillion out of about 30 to 33
million around a lot so it's all
depending on President Obama we have
high hopes you're making very good
noises and speedy noises about putting
in a simulation package one that
probably won't result but let me
these taxes you identify and will be
investing in the right areas of
technology and productivity so I'm quite
optimistic that we'll get that short
home Tim in the USA will recover I think
the big issue is Western Europe France
Germany Italy and Spain and UK will have
nicer coming death of deficits possible
increase in inflation and higher
long-term interest rates which won't be
help helpful and here we are having gone
through a recession being asked to lend
more and spend more and the long-term
the solution is for us the save more for
the faster growing markets are books on
the next dilemma of East End of the most
because that's where the savings is
where the cabin is and that's where I'm
continue to me so I'm not blooming
mother's being as most here and I'm
looking for a recovery in the early part
of 2010 real world and the financial
world and the Parkinson visible not